max Olek is a village Public Safety
Officer or vpso part of his job find and
hold criminals until state troopers step
in every day Oleg faces a daunting task
to fight crime he must sometimes arrest
friends neighbors and even family I was
born and raised here in quick look and I
know most of the people in this village
there's no strangers in this community
everybody knows everybody Olek became a
vpso 25 years ago to protect the you
pick way of life for centuries you pick
lived off the land hunting fishing and
trapping heart but in recent years ola
kissing his community deeply harmed by
alcohol a substance rarely abused until
bottled booze became widely available
alcohol is not our way of life and it's
devastating we did grow up with alcohol
and we don't know how to use it and we
wish use it the rundown village Public
Safety Office doubles as a makeshift
jail over here is our settle it has a
mattress this little hole is where we
check our prisoners and this if you're
sober enough we'll move you in here to
number three bollocks village outlawed
booze but smugglers started sneaking it
in
in Anchorage a fifth of whiskey costs
ten dollars here it can go for 300 the
square all the alcoholic beverages that
we seized ninety-five percent of our
costs are alcohol-related suicides
alcohol-related domestic violence
alcohol-related guns once used for
hunting are now used for crime we got
thirty forty guns in there the number of
konkan cause we went to and lucky that
we haven't been shot and I hope it
continues this is a really nice gun
doesn't have no attack but I got it from
a relative of mine and he was pointing a
gun at someone threatening to kill him
when confronted with heavy firepower
olic has little in the way of protection
I have a Taser that's only weapon that
we can use we carry a spot on also
handcuffed and capstan that sonic weapon
that we carry
despite the risks Olic is committed to
helping his people soon he'll get a
powerful new tool the village is about
to open a new public safety building
with safer cells and space to educate
the community about alcohol abuse Olek
worked tirelessly for over three years
to raise the funds he hopes the building
will finally be the resource he needs to
turn the tide on crime we need that
place without come in to need that